gaspard omar fabrice françois nicolas
pierre et pierre
je suis très honoré de remettre aux
meilleurs d'entre vous ce césar
emblématique
vous le savez ceux qui jouent un peu
moins bien ne leur ont pas l'occasion de
réfléchir à comment réussir à jouer un
peu mieux cette année
et pourquoi pas gagner la timbale
l'année prochaine et oui alors un
conseil pour accélérer le rythme de la
cérémonie si vous montez sur scène ce
soir
ne me remerciez pas à vos parents dans
soyons honnêtes sur usenet s'il vous
avez véritablement élevé avec attention
s'il vous avez donné tout l'amour que
vous méritiez vraiment vous ne seriez
pas dans le cinéma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bercy dans la catégorie césar du
meilleur acteur de second plan
les nommés sont valérie douville pour
stand by
[Applaudissements]
hervé jacomo pour harry un ami qui vous
veut plus
[Applaudissements]
christophe legendre pour le goût des
autres
et fabrice firmin pour saint cyr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
françois si on pouvait maintenant
remettre le césar je vais le faire
merci quand tu as payé - pardon je
voudrais juste a ajouté que pardon vous
êtes une magnifique comédienne et et je
trouve ça dommage que vous soyez pas
nommer ce soir le mérite donc oui pour
moi j'ai voté pour vous toute façon je
vous adore des pitchous petit mes
parents aussi et
vous êtes très joli et je peux le dire
parce que je suis juste à côté de vous
vous faites pas du tout votre âge et en
plus vous avez osé une tenue c'est très
courageux je trouve ça vraiment risque
que vous ayez jamais reçu deux prix
d'interprétation depuis le temps et que
personne ne vote jamais pour vous mais
mais je suis sûr que très bientôt vous
aurez un césar d'honneur associe vous
m'aurez avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est fier de sa femme il l'est mais
elle est enceinte
[Applaudissements]
sigourney weaver
malgré toutes les émotions que vous avez
pu ressentir malgré notre travail
acharné il est possible que vous vous
apprêtiez à traverser le fameux ventre
mou un delà de la cérémonie à le moment
on se fait chier pour parler cash moment
qui durent en général aux césars entre 2
à 3 heures quoi qu'il se met un peu
voilà il est drôle il est tendre il est
émouvant c'est une boule d'énergie et de
bonne humeur kad merad
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma chère kate qu'est tiki tiki ti cats
my sweet quête il n'est jamais trop tard
pour gagner à césar is never too late to
win césar car kate les bas tout finish
gosses kate winslet
[Musique]
danser
leïla bekhti géraldine nakache
quelle générosité vrai vrai don de soi
[Musique]
michel tu peut m'apporter un café s'il
te plaît à merci michel abadie pour en
bois beaucoup de café c'est pour ça
qu'on est si détendu l'ema au nom de
toutes les femmes dans les canons de
beauté ne correspond pas à la norme
merci merci d'avoir donné la parole en
femmes d'agir ne recourant pas en
paillettes de la chirurgie esthétique
comme c'est trop souvent le cas dans
d'autres professions
[Musique]
et boum nsa pour excuse moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya comme une petite
tension il tu m'en veux encore pour
l'année dernière non parce que je
voulais te dire que pas même si tu viens
cette cérémonie depuis prouve
eh ben tu fais pas du tout du tout
vieille et même j'ai l'impression que tu
rajeuni chaque année alors qu'en fait
non car ce n'est pas possible
l'équipe classée première en amérique et
pas des moindres michael douglas
comment résumer sa carrière au cinéma
c'est impossible michael douglas et
sinon dire que c'est un homme à femmes
quand même c'est un homme à femmes c'est
vrai au cinéma les femmes vous désirez
vous vous disiez appui au final ils ont
toujours un peu envie de vous butez
c'est étrange
elles ont toutes envie non mais c'est
tout tu regardes sharon stone glenn
close
l'autre qui me semblent démis moore
mon souhait les bleus en fait quand vous
disiez non c'était pas une blague quoi
une blague
oui à thonon en super drôle déjà pris
nos noms quand je dis non c'est non
alexandre savait bien qu'il y a des noms
qui veulent dire oui oui mais là c'est
un nom qui veut dire non je ne viens pas
aux césar en armure
[Musique]
pardon messieurs pardon pardon pardon
voilà môssieur astier fait du cinéma
maintenant qu'ils d'un fleuron se
découvre que sean penn est assis au
premier rang aux
à chaque fois les tâches et en moyens
ils étaient récit stib le mans attiré
par la jeune comédienne
n'y tenant plus il se précipite sur
scène dont la rejoindre
m
[Applaudissements]
y'a pas l'enjeu c'est normal on te l'a
pas mis le nez ça pour quoi parce que
voilà on sait bien que toute façon tu
vas dire le nom que tu veux donc c'était
il ya longtemps c'est j'ai mûri tu sais
ok je vous cherchez une enveloppe mais
je vais rester près de toi à temps diplô
me dis moi alors qu'est-ce qui se bat
non tu vois tu n'en n'ont rien à [ __ ]
vous filme à la lellouche à la louche
bouge pas bougez pas à la louche
aimez-vous c'est tout je tais toi à la
lellouche à la besson la maison fait un
travelling vous filme pas j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] ça travaille entre un travelling
et aux [ __ ] halak est chiche choc
excuse moi tom rochefort vite le
coupable mais pas vraiment toi mais
ouvreuse pas valide on est pas gêné
quatre pattes ils sont du ministre cinq
autos délation d'agnès merci c'est aux
boîtes le scénario c'est la colonne
vertébrale d'un film et la moelle
épinière que sont les que les actes et
les acteurs keith et les acteurs qui en
fait qui sent la moelle épinière que
sansan la colonne vertébrale sept mois
c'est la moelle épinière que sont les
acteurs ne trouvera ne trouverai ne
serait pas housse ou ce site où se
situer mais si vous tombez est bègue
loufoques pour clio il faut qu'il nous
quitte
que nous dit bon je vais partir mais
juste avant
[Applaudissements]